hi there I'm Beth Jos I'm a founder of
effective accelerationism today I'll
talk about Ai decentralization and
effective acceleration so what is
effective accelerationism at eak
essentially we believe that the engine
of progress of civilization is something
we call the techn capital machine which
is a cybernetic Loop between technology
and capital and that this sort of loop
is a form of intelligence that is
optimizing itself
uh to to grow civilization in terms of
its uh consumption of energy so in other
words it's trying to uh go up the cev
scill and we think this is a Force for
good that we should aim to accelerate
for example you know it is it is what is
behind uh Mor's law ultimately we
believe that the best way to accelerate
this machine is to have knowledge
sharing and free markets so that we
accelerate most effectively essentially
AI progress is crucial for this
acceleration and so so today I'll be
talking about how AI is going and some
roadblocks it's undeniable that
currently AI is undergoing a bull run of
Epic Proportions AI is is flourishing in
this era of distributed knowledge
distributed Capital there's an explosion
of archive papers of open- source AI
tooling models are are getting bigger
and bigger more and more computers being
invested more Technologies being uh
developed and more capital is being
injected so we're really in the boom
times powered by this sort of
distributed economy
of AI developers and and capital
allocators but the problem is that the
future of AI is really under threat from
forces of centralization and the big AI
players are currently meeting with uh
government officials spreading fud about
AI doom and using this fud in order to
secure regulatory capture they're trying
to control access to algorithms access
to models uh access to compute and break
our beautiful free market uh of ideas in
AI and of algorithms and models so why
should you care uh if you're into crypto
and then what can we do about it so why
should crypto care essentially this is a
fight you're familiar with this is the
sort of the top- down centralized
incumbents versus the bottom up
distributed Challengers these sort of
centralized institutions that are
inflationary they're trying to drive
prices up with overregulation versus
sort of the the free market that is
naturally deflationary drives rapid Tech
progress drives prices down erodes their
their Market power so they're they're
trying to render the sort of
decentralized alternatives to their
products uh quasi illegal or or just
buring them with tons of red tape and so
this is the same fight as Fiat versus
crypto all over again right and actually
there's many players that are common um
and so what can be done about it in the
short term so something we must fight is
we must fight for the right to keep open
source Source AI alive and healthy
they're trying to regulate away the
ability for people to open source large
models and share knowledge openly as we
know from the boom times we've seen
decentralization of research is best for
AI progress It's fundamentally better at
making breakthroughs it's much more
fault tolerant to corruption because
it's a decentralized system there's no
centralization of the locus of control
and and ultimately having more players
ensures sort of safety that no one
player becomes too powerful there's a
sort of safety through an adversarial
equilibrium generated by the the market
right so we want to fight over
concentration of AI power Fight The
Regulators and fight the centralizers
and maybe even give them a taste of
their own medicine and point to
antitrust if they cry for regulation due
to AI safety concerns so how do we
really win ultimately we have to use the
full power of the techn capital machine
so I propose an alliance to some extent
between uh decentralized Capital crypto
and our set of decentralized uh AI
Builders eak and uh adjacent orgs
ultimately a sort of decentralized
alliance between technology and capital
is the sort of engine that's very hard
to to stop and compete with and so what
does this mean well currently investors
that are pro deceleration and pro
centralization are are getting on cap
taes of AI companies so hopefully uh
cryp investors can get on more cap
tables of AI companies in terms of
technology and tooling dowo
infrastructure for alignment of
incentives and coordination is is really
missing to supercharge the open source
ecosystem and eventually The Regulators
and the centralizers are looking to do a
supply chain attack and bottleneck Us in
terms of ability to access compute and
so there might need to be a sort of
network State native AI infrastructure
so a cloud perhaps a network State cloud
that is the ultimate form of this
Alliance and so there's much to do much
to build and much to invest in so at any
given point you can ask yourself how can
I help the techn capital acceleration
how can I help the progress of AI and
remember this is for us to reach a
larger scope and scale of civilization
and to effectively accelerate my name is
bef Jos uh thank you very much for
listening